c'est une première dans la ville du
vésinet ce samedi 19 décembre
trois restaurants de la commune ont été
invités sur le marché cette opération
inédite a été lancée par le groupe géré
aux gestionnaires de l'espace
objectif aider les restaurateurs pendant
cette crise sanitaire
ils ont vu réinventer un petit peu leur
mode de distribution avec de la vente à
emporter et c est
avec la deuxième vague de nouveaux ont
fait face à une situation qui pourrait
être dur donc l'idée c'est de leur
permettre de renouer le contact avec
avec leurs clients avec les commerçants
et de réenclencher une dynamique
commerciale pour eux ce jour là ces
restaurateurs proposent aux clients de
déguster et d'emporter des plats
préparés cette opération soutenue par la
mairie semble les séduire
c'était une visibilité en plus on a bien
communiqué la sur les réseaux pour dire
à tout le monde qu'on était là que que
tout le monde passe nouveaux racks
asseoir un bon moment que les gens ne
nous oublie pas continuer à occuper le
terrain et que les gens nous oublie par
peut pas disparaître pendant toute la
fermeture c'est compliqué ça met en
avant les résultats qui sont en
difficulté ou non mais ça fait quand
même une certaine publicité pour eux et
je pense que ce serait une belle idée de
terrain le
ça nous aidera je pense que ça devrait
aussi pas mal de gens l'opération
pourrait être renouvelé d'ici le 20
janvier dans la ville date
prévisionnelle de la réouverture des
restaurants si la situation sanitaire le
permet en parallèle les restaurateurs
vont continuer le click and collect